قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكن ان الزمن اثبت ان اعتداء روسيا على
اوكرانيا فشل استراتيجي وان موسكو ستعاني
من تداعياته للسنوات
الفنلنديه هيلسنكيه ان الرئيس الروسي حول
منذ سنوات التفرقه بين الدول الغربيه وان
اهدافه اصبحت واضحه بعد شنه الحرب على
اوكرانيا
اثبت الوقت ان الاعتداء الروسي على
اوكرانيا كان اخفاقا استراتيجيا وان
تداعياته على روسيا ستتواصل لعده سنوات
عندما ننظر الى اهداف بوتين من الحرب فليس
هناك ادنى شك بان روسيا تريد فرض هيمنتها
العسكريه والاقتصاديه لكنها وصلت الى عزله
كامله في كل هذه المجالات فقد كانت موسكو
ترمي الى تقسيمنا لكنها لم تنجح والفضل في
ذلك يعود الى بساله الاوكرانيين
والاجراءات التي اتخذناها بمشاركه حلفائنا
لمسانده اوكرانيا